I'm going to show you the most awesome
stunk come them Uncle Tony you just
watch to see
[Music]
that has just been on my slam-dunk
little thing yeah so I hope she liked it
she did shocking that the redhead kid is
good at indoor sports that's right and
he's the original flying tomato 23 years
ago he lived life above the plastic rim
and as his homemade highlight reel
proves he is without question the
greatest nerf dunker of all time Michael
Jordan is a degenerate gambler with
stashes of secret kids all over America
so for me I'd rather be like Ryan if you
can't dunk you are meaningless you don't
see too many sneakers with a silhouette
of old Larry Bird draining a three hosts
rising is the most embarrassing thing
you can do to another man but we need a
new term for it because nobody has
posters anymore
you got animated gift or Jason Terry the
only reason I still respect my dad is
because I never saw him get dunked on
he'd lay out adjustable rims were
invented so white guys could spend a few
hours at black guy fantasy camp but
being able to dunk isn't just about race
it's about gender when a woman dunks
it's a top story on Jezebel for a month
try it with the real ball and I'm pretty
sure wearing heels is cheating too sure
the dunk contest sucks you're watching
some benchwarmer on the jazz 9th attempt
at jumping over but he gets a
perfect score because it's 2013 and
everything we do is hashtag amazing so I
thought it was time to educate a new
generation about his nerf this the boy
who started it all and then simply
walked away in a totally original
documentary series we're calling 30 for
30 point-0
[Music]
by the age of 12 Ryan was the greatest
nerf hoop dunker the world had ever seen
by 13 he was gone after almost 25 years
I wanted to understand the legend that
would end up shaking every doorframe in
America how long has it been since that
video was made 23 years now you know
winters are kind of long in Michigan so
you got some time to kill I was just
trying to get creative and I remember
one where I did the behind the back
dunks and then of course I throw the
ball between my legs it bounced off the
rim I don't get they say you can't
measure greatness but I think you can
and he was about five foot five what's
crazy to me is that by 91 he was the
greatest nerf dunker in history and I
think he was only making $10 a week in
allowance how old were you when you made
this video 12 or 13 how tall were you
5-3 I shattered my share back boys what
what Ryan dear to him it was out of this
world I tried to steal every movie head
he was supposed to be in the 1989 slam
dunk contest but luckily for Kenny
Skywalker Ryan had a social studies test
that day why were you look ordinate to
begin with you know back in the day
Jordan used to put out videos so I kind
of wanted to make my own kind of an
underground Street tape yeah let's talk
about your hair in that video what did
you think that was gonna hold you back
more in life being white or redheaded
probably redheaded Jordan didn't say the
same because he was going bald he said
that because he couldn't grow a big
curly red
wasn't a kid in America who didn't tuck
his shirt into his sweat pants to
imitate Ryan for those that didn't know
Russell Westbrook flat-out
stole Ryan's look wearing a big ass
Sally Jessy Raphael black was that the
happiest time of your life it was it was
good good the only reason they called
Dominique the human highlight film is
because what Ryan was doing in his
basement was not human
talk about the drugs there were rumors
of rim lauren and a mountain Dew
addiction but those claims are just
silly
why did you quit playing nerf basketball
my niece had a rare disease called the
Osgood slaughter what's the name of it
again
how's good slaughter it's named after
the doctor developed it it is very
serious I agree and he still should have
been on the 92 dream team overlayed Ryan
is Jesus Shuttlesworth do you think
Spike Lee wanted a cast Ray Allen a
spot-up jump shooter in the role of the
basketball Messiah no he want him Ryan
he wanted the nerf basketball Jesus but
he's grounded that week he couldn't do
the movie so when 0 Oscars what would
you go back and tell that 12 year old
version of yourself
not much yeah I think I just did it
right you know had fun who's your
favorite white dunker of all time I
don't know too many I mean one that I
remember back in the day was Chuck never
red berry white guy did the free-throw
line won the dunk contest with it and
then half a Blake Griffin was gonna save
life but we have to claim it we all
wanted to carry that nerf bar like right
and he was so good he had all the girls
his fifth grade girlfriend was on the
original season of basketball wives
she's still trying to milk that
three-day relationship what are you
doing now I work for a plastics company
are you married yes married you married
your childhood sweetheart
yes it's known her since third grade did
she fall in love with you because of the
basketball videos she knew that basement
pretty well there's two things I keep in
my pocket my wallet and my autograph
there if basketball bye Ryan
I hope it's him it's hard to read in the
phone did you raise the bar too high for
white kids in their basement I think I
kept it pretty low for them six feet six
inches isn't low my friend Ryan thanks a
lot in a beautiful house in a beautiful
wife Ryan was a cool dude that did not
complain when it rain he was the
ultimate trend setter before Ryan came
along it was just Mike and drills and
free throws the nerve root hasn't
survived the test of time because it's a
good toy
it's a four-dollar piece of it
survived because of Ryan Ryan I can't
help but notice you have a goal set up
you got one one the tank I would love to
see it sure
one two three
I thought I'd seen it all everything
they say about him is true the Legend of
Ryan track will never die
[Music]
out of my house
still best it's still with us
[Music]